[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce sillon
par les sports un peu particuliers
l'émission est toujours consacrée au
sport local comme d'habitude mais les
chroniqueurs ne sont pas avec nous en
plateau mais via écran interposé à cause
des mesures sanitaires du moment cinq
chroniqueurs vont participer à cette
émission à présentation on commence par
notre spécialiste cyclisme il était en
manque de six ans par les secours il m'a
régulièrement envoyé les messages
pendant le confinement pour me demander
la date de la future émission le pistard
du club de belgique 78 yens dujarrier
est avec nous quand allez-vous yam tous
je resterai bientraitance et le moment
confiné voilà confinés comme tout le
monde c'est vrai que bah ça a été une
période un peu compliquée et aujourd'hui
les kilos s'en font ressentir quoi là
alors on continue avec une fidèle de
cette émission elle et de versailles est
aussi pétillante et que pertinente elle
est spécialiste de pole dance elle
arrive en est toujours de la voir avec
celle avec nous sur cette émission de
notre ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange de versailles est
avec nous quand avez-vous hélène et bien
très bien au genre lequel cheville est
ravie de vous revoir tous vraiment
qu'elle quittait semaine mais c'est moi
qui sont passés et comme dit yann on est
un petit peu tard les kilos on va pas
fâchés mais on sent quand même le manque
de sport bon ça va bientôt reprendre
normalement également à l'or lui est un
petit nouveau de cette émission il fête
aujourd'hui son septième passage dans ce
talk espérons que ce chiffre 7 lui
portera chance il pratiquer plusieurs
disciplines et notamment le handball
fauteuil il est fan de saint-etienne
stéphane de bizet est avec nous comment
allez-vous stéphane où ça va bien ça va
bien oui oui vous faites un peu la boule
à non ouais non parce qu'on n'a pas
repris toujours le sport et puis ça
manque donc voilà bon ça manque la règle
c'est normalement ils sont en temps un
petit peu mais normalement ça devrait
aller
on termine par nos spécialistes rugby
si on commence par notre versailles et
on le surnomme le
gladiator et n'hésite pas à dire ce
qu'il pense et tout cela en à lire un
poil et détermination à pierre chevalier
du rugby-club de versailles est avec
nous pierre chevallier
quand allez-vous débat ça va très bien
très très très heureux comme les petits
camarades de se retrouver touche même
virtuellement
ça fait du bien de voir vos tronches les
uns les autres elles nous ont beaucoup
manqué pendant ces semaines de
confinement alors on termine par une
légende de cette émission c'est un roc
c'est un pic c'est un cap que dis je
c'est un cap c'est une péninsule putsch
genlis ex entraîneur de rugby de plaisir
est avec nous comment allez-vous gens
alors beaucoup de soleil on voit alors
écoutez moi cela très bien très très
bien et puis on est fiers très très
heureux de vous revoir la loi ou trois
ans ça fait du bien et ça fait plaisir
et bien plus je suis motivé donc je sais
pas en quoi on va parler mais je suis
motivé
alors juste à voir de quoi on va parler
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui
forcément nous allons parler de
couronnes à virus et de l'impact sur les
clubs sportifs locaux et le sport en
général
nous parlons agenda avec les différents
rendez-vous qui ont été annulés les jo
de tokyo la course paris versailles ou
encore l'open de france de golf coup de
projecteur également sur les
conséquences économiques sur les clubs
locaux mais tout d'abord zoom sur les
différents classements de cette saison
[Musique]
avec l'épidémie gobbi de 19 les
compétitions ne sont pas allées à leur
terme et un classement définitif a été
établi je vous propose un tour d'horizon
et on verra ensuite si ces classements
sont légitimes ou pas je vous poserai la
question chère chroniqueur en football
versailles montre à l'année prochaine en
nationale 2 en terminant premier devant
ivry de son côté trappe termine avant
dernier mais se maintient tout de même
en régionale 2 seule une formation
l'équipe 2 de versailles descendra dans
la poule suite aux décisions des
instances on écoute le président de
trappes et on est content parce qu'on
était mal parti en début de saison
et puis voir même à l'arrêt du
championnat on était quand même avant
dernier bon il nous restait encore quand
même cette nuit rencontre donc on est
les possibilités de se maintenir mais
bon à l'issue de cette des fouilles on
est sûr qu on est super contents et on
va pouvoir maintenant se consacrer à une
saison prochaine il a préparé au mieux
dans le championnat de première division
de district ces mots repas qui montre à
l'année prochaine en régionale 3 en
terminant premier devant abricots une
montée historique pour le club parce que
ça m'a crié au scandale quand la
décision est tombée ou quoi le zew
c'était tout à fait normal tu as fait
légitime que nous montions en terre on
était promue en première place et au
rugby en fédérale 2 depuis trois ans
plaisir restera une année de plus dans
cette division à la lutte pour le
maintien les plaisirs wa termine
finalement au 9e sur 12 équipes engagées
dans ce championnat après à 17 journées
on écoute le coach sébastien oqali
lustration pas avoir pu gagner
notre maintien d'une manière sportive
les frustrations également de ne pas
voir
si on a été capable d'aller chercher
fication parce qu'on était encore dans
dans la course à la 6e place
qualificative
donc voilà très très frustré on était
sur une très belle dynamique de phase
retour
une division en dessous en fédérale 3
verset en course pour une éventuelle
montée en fin de saison a vu sa saison
s'achever prématurément comme toutes les
autres équipes le rcv promu cette saison
termine donc quatrième
on va le plaisir ce maintien en
nationale 3 en terminant 8e de sa poule
et féminines de montier brut et le mans
en tête la montée après avoir terminé la
saison à la quatrième place
une semaine avant on était deuxième on a
perdu le dernier match qui en fait nous
nous conduirons nous laisse en fait en
nationale 2 pour la saison prochaine car
les compétitions où était à compter du
12 mars ont été complètement interrompue
et on a comme andy repris le solde à ce
moment là donc ça a été ça a été un peu
surprenant je reste en fait optimiste
pour pour l'année à venir la question
sur ce thème ces classements sont ils
légitimes
oui ou non vous votez alors voilà le
petit poucet louis pourriat dujarrier
non au pire chevallier oui oui pour
qu'est stéphane non pour vous jean et
non pour vous également hélène alors on
va faire un petit duel entre aller il ya
des pierres alors ils gagnent
vous êtes vous êtes pauvre simplement en
effet tous les championnats n'ont pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout jusqu'à leur terme
maintenant en ville si on avait une
situation exceptionnelle il a fallu
prendre des décisions et tranché le
championnat mais c'était avait déjà
dépassé plus de la moitié du plus de la
moitié avaient été faites
on était sur les phases de retour donc
on va pas dire que les classements
étaient entérinées bien sûr puisque
puisqu'il est resté d'aider des matches
à disputer mais voilà il y avait quand
même déjà un semblant et qu'on me voyait
ce défilé serait-ce le classement
commencé déjà avoir pris une bonne une
vraie allure donc
donc voilà oui bien sûr qu' il ya des
déçus maintenant légitime de toute façon
on a vécu une période exceptionnelle
vous pouvez pas finir finir les dix
championnat il fallait prendre une
décision
donc ceux qui ont gagné leur match et
qu'elle fait le boulot en amont en sont
récompensés
ceux qui espéraient encore pouvoir
briller sur la fin de saison et ben
fallait se réveille avant fallait faire
le taf h dès le départ et puis et puis
c'est tout ben tant mieux pour ceux qui
vont pu se sauver et qu'ils auraient pu
avoir une fin de saison un peu difficile
tant mieux pour ceux qui vont réussir à
monter en n'ayant pas eu à finir à finir
les matches ce sont des opportunités qui
ont été qui on est et qui ont été
saisies par part tout à chacun
aujourd'hui moi je pense que beaucoup de
sports collectifs peuvent déjà être
satisfait d'avoir eu un championnat il
faut pas où il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
énormément de sport individuel et on va
peut-être parlé tout à l'heure des
templiers des deux sports qui n'ont pas
plu du tout démarré leur championnat
je vais parler de mon fils qui était sur
sa deuxième année d'athlétisme et qui se
faisait une joie cette année après une
première année en bas des impros
maîtrise mais prometteuse pardon mais
après une première année où il voit là
il avait un peu vu truc et il s'était
dit purée prochaine je vais faire partie
des plus grands et je donne à de la
catégorie et donc je vais peut-être
pouvoir aller chercher des résultats
allait faire une belle finale régionale
eh bien ils ont même pas pu faire une
épreuve qualificative puisque la
première épreuve était le week-end qui a
suivi le confinement donc une saison
complètement blanche sans rien faire ils
n'ont fait que de l'entraînement donc
faut pas oublier voilà vous avez fait
des compétitions vous avez fait des
sports vous avez fait des matches nous
cyclistes la cycliste la saison commence
le premier week-end de mars
c'est à dire que les mecs ont fait deux
courses et maintenant on va leur dire eh
bien vous reprendrez en septembre
donc voilà vous avez déjà vécu une
saison vous avez vécu une saison qui
attend qui a été a été tronqué mais au
moins vous avez été jusqu'au bout oui je
finirai là-dessus gens c'était un beau
leur dire ce valet
je mets je mets un préambule tout de
suite tout de suite en action j'ai été
simplement pour pouvoir au moins
polémique est un petit peu sur cette
question là parce que évidemment
situation exceptionnelle décision
exceptionnelle
mais pour vraiment répondre
scrupuleusement à la question tient est
ce que ces classements sont légitimes je
réponds non puisque l'équité sportive ne
voulait pas n'est pas respectée et que
justement il aime le rappeler on a été
dans les phases retour et on sait très
bien où les sports collectifs alors pas
forcément les sports individuels mais
dans les sports collectifs que les
phases retour peuvent être peuvent être
palpitante et surtout aussi très
différente des phases aller donc là là
où je m'aime je trouve qu'ils ne sont
pas légitimes
évidemment en mettant une heure en
mettant des gros guillemets et une
énorme parenthèse sur cette période
exceptionnelle que nous voulons vivre
c'est que justement les le jeu était
fausse et les dés étaient pipés à ce
moment là parce que le parce que
justement toutes ces équipes qui
bataillait soit pour des qualifications
soit pour ne pas descendre ou finir
entre homos n'ont pas pu donc pas pu se
disputer en fait l'équité sportive et
les armes à la main et donc certes il a
bien fallu à vos statuts et et puis et
puis prendre une décision pour que la
saison
finalement à leur terme il y avait
également la possibilité de déclarer que
l'ensemble des étés était saison blanche
compte tenu compte tenu du contexte
évidemment il ya énormément de
conséquence à cette idée aurait eu
énormément de conséquence à cette
décision
ça n'a pas été le cas il a fallu prendre
une décision mais donc sportivement est
vraiment littéralement ces classements
ne sont pas légitimes
ils ont au moins le mérite d'exister
désormais avec en sanctionnant et en
concluant cette saison définitivement
très particulière pour tous les sports
collectifs et tout le sport en général
hélène est ce que vous en pensez qu'il
vous est possible
non je suis je suis d'accord avec
rihanna concernant
que faut pas attendre le dernier moment
pour se réveiller
c'est d'être efficace et aider burlats
reprend des arguments diane mais c'est
vrai que les rencontres sont aussi
aléatoire c'est du tirage au sort aussi
parfois c'est c'est des matchs sur
lesquels on compte
on y voit là et qu'on peut pas jouer
c'est une une organisation des kits qui
doit être comme ça à un instant t et
j'en sais quelque chose ou la non c'est
vrai que c'est c'est quand même mieux
quand est jugé sur une saison complète
maintenant voilà c'est de circonstance
exceptionnelle il faut statut et
heureusement voilà en espérant que
l'année prochaine puis savoir que chacun
puisse aussi tiré la leçon de être
performant d'essayer de travailler en
vue d'être stratégique début donc on
verra ça l'an prochain stéphane de
business qui a pas un problème aussi au
niveau des instances parce que
finalement tout on a eu ces règles il ya
eu la fédération française de foot qui a
établi sa règle a également eu le
handball qui a établi sa règle avec des
deux montées de descentes comme
d'habitude la fédération française de
football c'est une montée et une
descente dans les championnats amateurs
est ce que finalement il y aurait il
n'aurait pas fallu que tout le monde
s'accorde stéphane oui oui oui zoo
réduire m il aurait dû tout se mettre
d'accord là dessus mais moi je suis
d'accord avec yann le championnat s'est
arrêté un instant paix dont ceux qui
m'ont dit montre ce qui dispense
décembre tout s'arrête à quand la
décision a été prise de d'arrêter sa
cause du coronavirus après après j'en
ris par exemple enfin stéphane par
exemple il y à il ya des équipes qui se
sauve finalement trappe se sauve
finalement la décision a été la décision
a été prise d'arrêter de tout arrêter un
instant précis donc c'est comme si le
championnat s'arrêtait donc ceux qui
montent montent ce qui des stands d
entre nous c'est comme ça et puis voilà
jean vous a pas entendu sur la question
encore vous avec les émoticônes non mais
moi j'ai moi j'ai voté contre
j'ai voté contre j'étais dans ma vie
depuis hier et ce n'est pas pour
débattre c'était parce que là
contrairement à ce qui a été dit je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord sur le fait
qu'il fallait faire le nécessaire en
début de saison parce que là encore
collectif une c'est jaune c'est une
saison entière et que on prépare pas une
saison pour gagner tout le début et
après déroulé le reste de la saison
c'est pas vrai c'est pas possible donc
une saison c'est une saison complète et
que le fait que je dois pas aller au
bout c'est un petit peu tronquée les
sceptiques diront la pousse dit il
fallait bien prendre une décision en ce
qui concerne le rugby il n'y a pas trop
déçu puisque a pas de décembre
donc on ne peut pas dire que les clubs
fassent la gueule jusqu'il ya que des
montées jusqu'à de national
il ya quand régionales où il ya quand
même quelques quelques descentes mais
sinon si si si si non il n'y a pas de
déçu au niveau des clubs
il fallait prendre cette décision mais
par contre au niveau des résultats
sportifs
sportivement une saison c'est une saison
complète ou de flèches que quand un
entraîneur arrive il faut du temps et ça
se fait pas d'un coup de baguette
magique donc une saison est largement
tiré c'est même pas suffisant
quelquefois on pouvoir voir les fruits
et les bénéfices de son de son travail
donc voilà c'est dans ces cas de figure
j'avais parlé des carrières
oui je parle anglais et comme gens comme
jean vient juste de le dire c'est qu'une
saison ça ne se joue pas sur une période
dans la saison ça joue sur toute une
saison donc ça veut bien dire que à
partir du moment où on joue on joue la
saison en entier et bien du coup mais
les performances ont été réalisées
depuis le début doivent compter et
doivent permettre de pouvoir finaliser
un classement à n'importe quel moment
moi je reste je reste dans ma décision
et parce que dis-je en jeu
je pense que ça va dans mon sens mais ce
qu'il n'aurait pas fallu que toutes les
instances je reviens à ma question que
toutes les instances se concertent ou
même concept les clubs parce que les
clubs n'ont pas forcément tous s'étaient
concertés dans cette décision c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible vous avez d
iliad il ya des championnats il y a dix
douze 12 clubs d'autres y en a huit
enfin voila c'est chaque sport a ses
spécificités
donc une revanche et en plus et en plus
chaque sport n'était pas non plus au
même moment dans sa saison si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est à dire qu'il y
avait peut-être même à peine commencé
les matches aller alors que d'autres les
avait déjà entamé très largement par
exemple pourra prendre l'exemple des
templiers d'elancourt qui n'ont commencé
leur saison que en janvier turgeon le
baseball on va en parler juste après le
baseball n'a pas du tout commencé sa
saison
et voilà donc du coup on ne peut pas
uniformisé et dire ce sera la même chose
pour tout le monde puisque tout le monde
n'était pas même au même point dans son
championnat
alors on va passer maintenant à une
nouvelle thématique mais on continue à
parler de ce corps navires us et de ses
conséquences sur les clubs locaux et
notamment financier à cette saison au
stade jean maréchal de monti le
bretonneux va sonner creux les cougars
le club de baseball on aura justement
qu'il devait reprendre au printemps le
joueront finalement aucun match à cause
du courant la virus la fédération a
décidé d'annuler la saison à coup dur
financier pour les dirigeants du club
privé notamment de merchandising et de
buvette
c'est pas qu'on soit vraiment je dirais
en complet danger mais c'est
relativement inquiétant quand même c'est
une situation vraiment inattendu les
temps sont durs pour les cougars
mais on a quand même la chance d'être
soutenue toujours au niveau au niveau
département au niveau de la région au
niveau de la mairie au niveau de
l'agglomération qui n'ont pas retiré en
fait
les budgets qui était allouée cette
saison blanche pourrait également avoir
un impact sur le secteur sportif les
cougars qui évolue en première division
pourrait perdre certains de leurs
meilleurs joueurs ce qui pourrait jouer
contre nous malheureusement c'est
aujourd'hui les championnats allemands
tchèques italiens sont en passe de
reprendre puisqu'ils ont des situations
moins perturbé que les nôtres il se
pourrait vraiment que on est des joueurs
qui avaient déjà été contacté cet hiver
puisque l'année dernière on a fait une
3e place en coupe d'europe dès on a on a
des joueurs qui avaient déjà été
contactées qui ont toujours des contacts
et qui seraient susceptibles de trouver
d'autres clubs
les cougars de montier les bretons
espèrent désormais rouvrir cet été pour
les stages d'animation pour les jeunes à
partir de la deuxième quinzaine de
juillet l'équipe première devrait quant
à elle reprend du coup en 2021
une petite réaction par rapport aux
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux de
genre oui bah écoute via l'argent
comment pas de chance y'a pas de chance
mais voit le championnat est fait comme
ça ils doivent commencer à jouer à
partir du à partir du mois de mars
jusqu'à une certaine période d'un oui on
peut dire que c'est pas de chance mais
c'est ccb règle est cuit et puis et puis
c'est tout donc j'ai légion n'a vécu
exactement la même chose avec un avec
maurice en quoi on devait commencer la
première compèt le léthé conflit 18 donc
ça c'était le 21 mars quoi donc d'un
thème et franchement on y en a on a on a
espéré très longtemps à se dire si le
confinement dure qu'un mois mois et demi
on pourra peut-être faire deux trois
manches qualificatives qui permettrait
de faire une finale au mois de juin et
puis ben le temps avançant et lille
voyant la situation la situation en
ayant assez vite résignés et on reprend
l'entraînement seulement aujourd'hui
alors moi mes enfants ont eu la chance
de pouvoir courir et s'entraîner parce
que je lisais je les ai pas laissé à
rien faire je pense que c'est très
important donc de pouvoir continuer
d'avoir une activité sportive mais mais
c'est pas le cas pour ses pas le cas
pour tout le monde et ça va créer ça va
créer des décalages dans les laits dans
les mois et années à venir je pense je
n'hésitais mondialisée cet apport la
pierre chevallier stéphane bizeau oui je
veux dire c'est vraiment pas de chance
parce que nous jouons rugby fauteuil
pour une fois on était qualifiés en
finale de la ligue 1 pour jouer le titre
de champion de france et on avait la
chance de d'arriver au bout et au final
il y aura rien du tout donc mais pas de
bol on va retravailler pour l'an
prochain pour faire avec c'est tout
verdier il ya une vraie donne qu on voit
d'ailleurs au niveau du sport
professionnel au dessus du sport amateur
c'est ce qui concerne est ce qu'il va
concerner les calendriers et là
effectivement c'est un concours de
circonstance et c'est donc exceptionnel
et pas de chance il ya certes un sport
qui ont des saisons qui sont décalées et
là sur sept sur sept ce phénomène
complètement imprévisible il ya ce qu'il
y a ceux qui n'avaient pas encore
démarré les saisons et qui sont pris
plein de fois une annulation il y avait
même pas de débat sur savoir ce qui
allait se passer ou ce qui est comment
la saison et pouvoir se dérouler et puis
à les autres et maintenant à une des
conséquences que l'on peut peut-être
souhaité sur 7
sur cette sortie de crise après deux
spécialités
c'est très bon maintenant comment le
sport amateur et sport professionnel va
s'organiser notamment au niveau des au
niveau des cadences des calendriers et
d'éventuelles phases finales quelles que
soient les sports il y en a qui y aura
il y aura des heureux il y aura des
déçus hélène les heureux et déçu je
pense finalement
quand même pas mal de pas mal de déçus
par rapport au nombre d'heureux
maintenant comme des pierres des quais
lâchons pas seulement des décalages
doute at on a aussi les décalages
financiers et décalages droite dans
permet une pratique non on n'avait pas
sorti dans les maisons celle là en mai
soit d'accord ou pas d'accord
malheureusement voilà à kickoff tirer un
petit peu hors épingle du jeu des choses
négatives alors les cougars ne sont pas
les seuls à avoir des problèmes
financiers beaucoup de clubs sont en
difficulté dans le département notamment
à cause des recettes de buvette et oui à
certains clubs arrivent tout de même à
s'en sortir on écoute legault président
de l'union rugby centre 78 lionel
garrigues
on a vu notre trésorerie sensiblement
baissé pas de manière grave mais
bénéficiant pour qu'on puisse demander
d'ailleurs certaines eric maurin commune
en cours comme voisins bretons ne ont
fait le saut mais avant ce soit en
propose effectivement de nous aider ils
ont été très solidaires pareil pour sky
et toutes les luttes auxquelles
entremêlées qu'ils représentent et
toutes les autres institutions qu'ils
représentent
urs et 78 alors on va donner la parole
aux spécialistes de la buvette à genlis
pierre chevallier jambes
est-ce que la buvette est importante
pour un club les recettes de billetterie
est importante
apparemment apparemment oui il est vrai
qu il est vrai que ce lait ou bien sûr
les clubs amateurs
les recettes les recettes la buvette
fait partie des grosses recettes
surtout quand des clubs fonctionnent
bien et c'est un manque à gagner qui est
qu est assez important est effectif
le second à mon avis est ce qui va être
plus important m et par les partenariats
parce que même situation exceptionnelle
et belle des entreprises
les bulles et de partenariats vont être
les premiers supprimés et c'est ce qui
va faire énormément de mal au club aux
clubs amateurs d'art amateur dans toutes
les disciplines confondues
il ya trois il ya trois risques dans les
clubs amateurs et dans les budgets des
clubs amateurs le premier on vient de le
citer et j'en veux rappeler c'est tout
ce qui est lié à la convivialité et à
l'est d'el du rugby pour ce qui concerne
le rugby mais je pense que dans les
autres sports c'est la même chose
c'est-à-dire les gantiers des ventes
quand il ya des ventes additionnelles à
la buvette à la boutique ce genre de
choses dans un club amateur c'est peu de
chose mais ça fait partie intégrante du
budget
le deuxième risque c'est sur l'essai sur
les des pertes éventuelles de licenciés
c'est à dire que pendant cette période
là qui a été très particulière les uns
et les autres ont arrêté les activités
option 1
option 2 on a découvert d'autres et
option 3 finalement se tourner vers
d'autres même d'autres loisirs tite le
sport et d'autres loisirs il ya
évidemment le les rythmes de vie les
rythmes des études qui joue là dedans et
à une baisse de licenciés galbès de
presse de baisse de budget et le
troisième est ça qui va être on en est
qu'au début qui va être à mon avis assez
dramatique c'est effectivement les
partenariats
on va lire partenariats privés pour un
club amateur mais l'espoir de les
sponsors et les partenaires avec
certaines certaines entreprises et
commerces qui vont l'être dans la
fournaise
on a dans les clubs amateurs de santé
péjorative des partenaires de petite
taille des petits commerces dettes des
petites entreprises pme tpe et elle
voudrait dans la tourmente et notamment
on attend le on attend le vraiment le
gros creux de la vague en septembre et
donc à l'heure où on fait des budgets
pour la saison suivante ça va ça va être
très impactant il faudra à ce moment là
à les voir d'autres d'autres partenaires
qui eux on puisse tirer leur épingle du
jeu dans pendant la pendue confinement
alors la question sur ce thème est ce
que le colis de 19 ce qu ils 19 est une
catastrophe pour les structures locales
une catastrophe un geste bien là-dessus
structures locales et également pour les
clubs comme vous pour vous par exemple
est ok catastrophe hélène justement je
vous donne la parole à l'ats terry parce
que les répercussions elles sont pas
seulement à l'instant t où on à la
structure permet
la par obligation on a aussi la perte de
faire la guerre aux clients les gens qui
se tendent vers des choses à uashat mak
ont finalement son n'aime pas forcément
sécurisé et sécurisant mais revient on a
les oueds la partie financière l'argent
qui ne rentrent pas qui va pas rentrer
pendant des semaines parce que le temps
que les personnes reprennent recond
somme c'est là la rentrée là clairement
elle pour moi aller et je pense beaucoup
de clubs elle est quand même
relativement martin c'est c'est quand
même un peu compliqué donc voila c et en
plus on n'est quand même pas pas
énormément nu ce qu'est ministère des
sports et cetera donc j'en ai un peu de
sport le pole dance un mini oui mais
voilà mais après on nous la pole dance
fait partie de la fédération française
de danse donc voilà on verra caché en
une tâche et voilà on est quand même
client route n'est pas du tout à pas
mais voilà on est pas on n'est pas aidés
on vient seulement d'avoir les quelques
informations voire potentiellement d
ouvrir alors pendant une orange jaune et
verte
mais on a eu des réponses avant donc je
pense que jean c'est pareil tous les
sports ont eu les informations vraiment
décalé en décalé c'est le tandem elles
sont là ce soir c'est catastrophique
parce que il ya la fermeture il ya tout
d'après en fait et c'est celle après
qu'ils aient presque plus d'effrayantes
la ferme
alors on a l'impression quand même que
les collectivités locales aident ces
sites et notamment le cas pour lui
verser 60 18 pour les cougars
montigny-le-bretonneux
c'est un peu le rôle des collectivités
locales à votre avis jarrier elles sont
des jeux c'est pierre avait envie de
parler l'a donc moi je vais pas dire
grand chose là dessus les collectivités
locales sont déjà énormément sollicités
au cours de nos cours de l'année mais
est ce que ça peut permettre des
structures locales juste allait perdurer
attention il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que les collectivités locales avec
quoi elle fonctionne avec quoi elles
fonctionnent les côtes ibériques
collectivités locales fonctionnent avec
nous
impôts et donc si les collectivités
locales emprunte pour pouvoir permettre
de continuer et magna un moment où il
faudra rembourser
et on remboursera via nos impôts tout
économiquement
économiquement ce sera compliqué sera
compliqué sur le long terme et toujours
ce sont les mêmes qui est qui qui
paieront on a en a eu un double contexte
particulier le protect sportif on vient
d'en parler mais il ya aussi un contexte
pour les quand on parle de collectivités
locales et celui de l'organisation des
élections municipales avec ce premier
tour qui a été très controversé le
deuxième tour qui arrive d'ici trois
semaines et avec des équipes qui sont
soit constitué ces restes soient qui
sont qui ont été élus au premier tour et
qui ont pu se réunir très récemment là
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir statuer et
constituer les conseils municipaux
quand il quand il s'agit et puis à les
autres il ya toutes celles qui n'y sont
pas encore élu et donc c'est l'ancienne
équipe qui est aux manettes et ça c'est
ça c'est vraiment très particulier pour
pouvoir gérer un budget qui peut ne pas
ne plus être le vôtre à partir du 28
juin et c'est celui d'une autre équipe
très rapidement pour cette partie
budgétaire des collectivités locales
yann rappeler un certain nombre de
points qui sont constitutifs des budgets
des collectivités locales il faut pas
oublier aussi c'est que nos à versailles
en a la chance d'être dans une ou plutôt
une grande agglomération une grande
ville donc elle donc à un budget
conséquent mais ça veut dire aussi qu'il
ya énormément d'associations sportives
culturelles entre autres à soutenir et
donc ils vont tout avoir le même besoin
elel le disais c'est plutôt
catastrophique pour ces petites
structures là parce que non seulement il
ya eu deux mois d'interruption
d'activité mais en plus on n'est qu'au
début on fait des effets des effets
économiques que l'on peut que l'on peut
redouter
ça va arriver en septembre salariés en
octobre avec des défaillances un petit
peu partout et des collectivités locales
avec le budget des impôts plus
éventuellement d'emprunt à rembourser il
y en a raison de le rappeler
elles vont avoir énormément de dossiers
sur le feu et peut-être pas de quoi de
quoi
subvenir à tous les besoins c'est quoi
la solution finalement stéphane de bizet
il faut faire le dos rond pendant
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
on est les structures sportives bon je
pense moi par exemple je vois je parle
toujours de mon club de rugby fauteuil
mais on compte beaucoup sur les recettes
pour pouvoir financer des fauteuils
pouvoir faire venir des des personnes
pour renforcer le club et
malheureusement cette année on n'a pas
pu faire de recettes
on va à partir du corim 19 donc ça va
faire mal mais va falloir qu'on en
compte comme je dis qu'on fasse avec en
fait ça va ça va être dur il y aura
probablement pas de nouveaux fauteuils
pour l'an prochain on va devoir faire
avec les anciens qui ont déjà pris pas
mal de coups et je pense que ça va ça va
être dur mais je l'avais bien passé
thématique il est un point sur lequel on
il faut il faut miser c'est la
solidarité solidarité des licenciés avec
chacun de leur club chaque chaque
licencié doit être au soutien de ces
clubs dans les bons comme dans les
mauvais moments et c'est là qu'on va
voir justement les vraies valeurs du
sport
alors on passe maintenant à notre
nouvelle thématique le corrélat virus a
également des impacts sur les grands
événements sportifs locaux et mondiaux
les jo-2020 de tokyo ont été déplacées à
2021 du 23 juillet au 8 août pour être
précis de sportifs évinois pouvait
potentiellement y participer le cavalier
victor l'évêque 21 ans et thomas baruch
32 ans licencié au cercle nautique de
versailles il a remporté une médaille de
bronze lors des derniers jo de rio on
écoute justement la réaction de thomas
baroque que ça change c'est beaucoup
d'incertitudes en plus parce que même
aujourd'hui on sait pas exactement
comment va se dérouler les mois qui ne
s'est pas encore de des nouvelles dates
des olympiques 2020 qui est d or en 2021
donc c'est pas mal d'incertitudes on
essaie de continuer à s'entraîner de là
elles passeront plus tous les jours même
si les échéances sont plus lointaines en
aviron la seule échéance internationale
qui reste pour cette saison ce serait
les championnats d'europe qui
déroulerait début octobre
alors victoire avec les lui a plus
jeunes c'est un sportif en devenir et
fait notamment partie de la génération
2024 on écoute on pourrait
maginez que ça me permet d acquérir
encore plus d'expérience pour les
prochaines et puis la particularité de
mon sport c'est qu'on ait deux puisqu'il
ya le cavalier bien sûr le cheval voilà
j'avais un cheval qui était en super
forme qui m'appelle mieux qualifié
l'année dernière cette année ils étaient
voilà prêt après a démarré cette saison
olympique
maintenant quelle sera la situation
année prochaine je peux pas le dire en
dehors de ces deux champions d'auterive
ynwa devait partir comme les pistards de
l'équipe de france sur piste du cou qui
s'entraîne aux ventes de 50 ans divine
ou encore des membres du club de très
action de poissy comme cassandre
beaugrand la question sur ce thème le ce
report des géo est il forcément une
mauvaise nouvelle pour les sportifs y
vinoy oui ou non parce que c'est
forcément une mauvaise nouvelle
elle est convoquée ce jour michael vous
permet pas un guerrier et ben je me
permets parce qu'on est loin aujourd'hui
voyez donc je peux alors et périls
stéphane de viser 50 50
bon alors on va c'est parce qu'on votait
ont été données aux agents par exemple
qui a été un très bon élève
aujourd'hui stéphane assez de réponses
de suisse à st-gall égarements nom des
gens qui veulent pas trop se mouiller ça
alors vous qui voulez vous mouiller
justement voilà qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais moi je trouve je trouve que
une préparation une préparation sportive
de haut niveau quelles qu'elles soient
quelle discipline que tout soit ces
sceptiques comme dans sa définition
c'est une préparation
et lorsque le jour j arrive un angle
c'est énorme on le dit on le dit depuis
fois sur le plateau on en a parlé
le fait de prolonger d'un an sans
compter certains sportifs je parle je
vais devancé yann qui est sa spécialité
dans le cyclisme on a des sportifs qui
était un petit peu limite limite au
niveau de l'âge et un an lorsqu'on
arrive un petit peu à la fin mais c'est
très important
c'est une année qui risque d'être bien
gérée qui vont peut-être remettre
remettre même en question la composition
de l'équipe de l'équipe de france
en parlant en parlant pour le pour le
cyclisme mais c'est vrai que une année
c'est long c'est londres dans les deux
sens
selon dans le bien et dans le mauvais
donc ceux qui étaient prêts ce qu'ils
étaient prêts là pour cette région ne
seront pas spécialement dans un an
et peut-être aussi il est sûr qu'on peut
aussi voir comment y arriver maintenant
d'accord en fait je pense qu'aujourd'hui
si vous voulez parler de grégory baugé
par exemple il y avait 36 ans et voilà
les voiries beau jeu grégory baugé pour
lui je pense que c'était ma barrows
c'est thomas barrau qui à 32 ans
également de 32 encore voilà c'est
encore des belles années 32 33
mais c'est vrai que je pense que pour
grégory c'est vraiment le il ya
certainement fallait d'autres sportifs
dans le monde où c'est le même cas mais
il s'est vraiment charnière c'est à dire
que voilà il est prêt physiquement il
s'entraîne et c'était c'était bon le
fait que en plus en dans l'équipe de
france il y a des jeunes qui arrivent et
qui pousse et ces jeunes et bien une
année pour pouvoir acquérir de
l'expérience supplémentaire va faire qui
vont qui vont peut-être exploser et du
cou grégory même s'il arrive à maintenir
son niveau son niveau de 2 cette année
et ce qui est ce qui est très très dur
parce que parce que ben voila quand
quand on a une échéance comme ça hein
un objectif comme celui là est bien se
dire d'un seul coup ce sera un an de
plus donc il va falloir continuer à
faire les mêmes efforts pendant un an de
plus c'est vraiment très très longue
très très dur je souhaite agrégat qui
soit qui qu'il soit à tokyo la prochaine
mais voilà je me dis que un ryan et la
halle qui s'était mais complètement
ratée sur les sur les coupes du monde de
l'hiver une année pour pouvoir justement
prouvé qu'il est capable et de et de
servir de cette nouvelle expérience
d'avoir raté une saison complète ben ça
peut être vraiment faire la différence
un tome derache qui étudia le gériez
certains cyclistes vont profiter de la
situation
les légionnaires marianela le sébastien
ogier qui ont moins de 25 ans mais il
est complètement c'est à dire que en
fait il ya deux viennent de catégorie
elle est plus de 30 ans qui vont
vont avoir une année qui risque d'être
vraiment pénalisant pour eux il ya les
moins de 25 qui vont avoir une année
supplémentaire qui risque d'être
bénéfique pour eux et puis après il ya
une troisième catégorie c entre 25 et 30
et euh ça change pas grand chose voilà
c'est juste une remise en question
maintenant il faut faire tomber de
questions du changement de programmation
et puis repartir pour apprendre plus
maintenant il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que les anglais depuis alors je
vais en parler de cyclisme de cyclisme
sur piste mais les anglais depuis deux
olympiades avait cette capacité à être
prêt pour les jeux olympiques et donc à
faire des programmations d'entraînement
non plus sur une saison mais sur quatre
juste après les jeux de londres ou juste
après les jeux de rio
il partait faire une année sabbatique et
pendant une année on ne voyait que des
jeunes venir remplacer les remplacer les
anciens et puis et bien au bout à deux
ans et demi de l'échéance et bien les je
vais j'ai bouffé leur nom mais est bien
qu'il reprenait et il revenait sur la
piste après avoir vu d'autres sports vu
d'autres activités pendant un an et demi
et 7 aérer la tête et donc qu'ils
avaient une programmation de deux ans et
demi pour préparer une échéance
olympique
aujourd'hui ça va être vraiment vraiment
différent et je vais prendre juste là un
exemple mais usain bolt faisait ça
faisait la même chose
voilà j'ai reçus y est je pense que
l'élève qui est-ce qui jouent vraiment
et pour répondre à la question c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle c'est justement le
côté complètement aléatoire on a parlé
des saisons qui doit ce qui doit se
dérouler entièrement du début à la fin
et là on a un an il peut se passer
tellement de choses mentalement
physiquement que évidemment les cartes
sont redistribuées complètement rebattu
et je n'ai rien on est ouais on est on
est encore pas sûr que les gigots et
lieu l'année prochaine en 2021 hollen un
victor l'évêque aussi et dans ce cas de
figure avec un choix l'huile un cheval
en plus qu'il est en forme en même temps
que lui c'est notre problématique
oui et puis même
on était très proche de très proche de
l'échéance donc c'est d'autant plus dur
parce que là il était vraiment dans on
donne tout on est là on est prêt à y
aller et là on parle de carrément un an
il peut y avoir un impact mentale
justement il n est bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr le cheval alors si on parle ans
si on parle de cheval le cheval voilà il
faut qu'ils puissent tenir ce rythme là
d'entraînement pendant une année
supplémentaire qui mentalement il joue
il faut réussir à tenir ses
entraînements comme ça et c'est quand
même compliqué une année supplémentaire
pour n'importe quel sportif d'ailleurs
c'était face de mise et je vous donne la
parole
apprends passera une autre thématique
non annoncée avec l'intéressant vous
avez pas vu les actions non je veux dire
il ya ceux qui vont être lésés à ceux
qui s'étaient préparés pour cent et qui
au final ma n'y aura rien il ya ceux
aussi qui se sont qualifiés de justesse
pour aller aux jeux olympiques et qui
vont pouvoir avoir un an de plus pour se
préparer et pour eux je pense que ce
sera tout bénef
et je parle encore de l'équipe de france
de rugby fauteuil qui a dû passer par un
tournoi qualificatif pour aller à tokyo
donc ils vont pouvoir retravailler en
plus pour être prêt le jour j
alors en tout cas en exemple beaucoup
rapidement il ya déjà il faut qu'on
arrête on peut prendre l'exemple de
france un service qui a eu 1 comment un
projet qui est arrivé très tard et en
effet pour eux c'est une aubaine que les
je veux les jeux paralympiques soit
décalé dame enfoncé ce qui va participer
aux prochains jeux paralympiques un
joueur à elle sur vélo un vélo situant
en tandem en tandem avec mon chien vous
mangez un partenaire des jeux de dés des
championnats du monde de rio
tout à fait j'ai juste
en jeu les personnes sélectionnées au
les sorties scolaires prochaine les
sélections peuvent sans doute en plus
évoluées c'est à dire qu'on peut avoir
des personnes sélectionnées cette année
qui ne sont pas forcément le robien
c'est pour cela que ça va être difficile
vraiment comme disait yann ya aussi la
contrainte d'âge mais de s'être entraîné
de demain une année supplémentaire pour
peut-être pas y aller à jean va faire
les jo c'est moi qui l'ait dit la limite
d'âge pour un sportif de haut niveau la
préparation elle et elle est allée
enfin le mental est très important et
c'est beaucoup de sacrifices aussi
l'entraînement et c'est vrai que là se
dire qu'ils vont faire les mêmes
sacrifices continus les un sacrifice un
an de plus mais ça peut être très très
dur pour un bonbon jarrier le groupe
je suis désolé faut avancer dans
l'émission en tout cas on leur souhaite
beaucoup de courage pour la préparation
de ces jeux olympiques 2020 en espérant
qu'ils aient lieu cette fois ci on va
t'en parler du nouveau calendrier 2020
pour le sport yvelinois beaucoup de
rendez vous ont été annulés c'est le cas
de l'open de france de golf à saint
quentin en yvelines
l'événement phare du monde golfique
france a été annulée suite à l'épidémie
de couronnes un virus
vous vous en doutez le rendez vous n'a
pas pu être reportées à cause d'un
calendrier surchargé en écoute la
réaction du directeur général de la
fédération française de golf
christophe muniesa c'est un crève coeur
pour la fédération mais pour les
golfeurs aussi de ne pas pouvoir
profiter de cet open national
après c'est une évidence de le dire mais
on comprend très bien que le contexte
sanitaire actuelle ne nous permettait
pas d'organiser l'épreuve dans de bonnes
conditions
tu es un triste de voir deux réalités
auxquelles on est confronté et on a
envie de se projeter d'ores et déjà vers
l'édition 2021 alors je vais vous
proposer plusieurs événements et à
chaque fois il faudra dire si oui ou non
il fallait annuler l'épreuve
alors est-ce qu'il fallait annuler cet
open de france de golf féminin
oui ou non non au oui
on vous a pas vu jean voilà enfin petit
duel aller retour entre pierre chevalier
et il ya du jarrier ya dujarrier non le
golf c'est le premier sport car prix etc
a repris après l'or après le confinement
puisque c'était le sport le plus facile
pour pouvoir conserver la distance à
sion les distances sociales donc je ne
mange je ne comprends pas et en effet
alors après la seule chose que je peux
comprendre c'est par rapport à l'attrait
du public un public c'est toujours
beaucoup plus difficile à gérer mais
après en terme de compétition les les
courses a pas de l'école fait c'est
assez simple de gérer cette distance
sociale donc dommage
et puis après je pense aussi que le fait
d'en face ont des difficultés
financières seront pour sûrement pour
tout le monde même les golfs en prendre
à eux ne prendra aussi ça ça claque
comme tout le monde
comme dit christophe milliers d'heures
le dg de la fédération française de golf
c'était un crève coeur mais de toute
façon c'était c'était c'était évident
qu'il fait qu'il fallait le qu'il
fallait annuler eu précisément pour les
pour les données qui ne permettait pas
de le faire de le faire avec public
direction rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de
tribunaux gulf ans je suis on suit les
parties ou quasiment au plus proche
c'est ça qui est fantastique en
conditions normales de jeu c'est qu'on
est au plus près des champions nationaux
et internationaux
donc là ça aurait pu à la limite se
jouer à huis clos mais en fait ce qu'il
ne faut pas oublier c'est que on sortait
déjà d'une d'âpres négociations avec
l'european tour
pour l'organisation et surtout pour une
bonne date de l'open de france puisque
vous souvenez que en 2019 ça s'était
joué en octobre et que là on se
réjouissait déjà de le revoir sur le
champ sur sa place historique fin juin
début juillet mais mais les conditions
sanitaires et d'anticipation évidemment
et les skis et ski est imposé dans les
cahiers des charges de l'événementiel
dès qu'on reçoit du public
de toute façon imposer ses décisions
c'était un secret de polichinelle de
pouvoir espérer qu'il soit joué qui soit
jaune aux dates
aux dates prévues et là il a été non pas
reporter purement et simplement annulée
à cause de ces de ses négociations avec
l'european tour qui sont qui rendr lui
qui rend de l'open de france non
prioritaires par rapport à des gros
tournois anglo saxons où américains et
il y avait plus de place dans le
calendrier dans le calendrier de fin
d'année à partir de septembre pour
reporter l'open de france
donc malheureusement vos obligations de
l'aduler dans ces conditions fierté bien
d'accord était bien d'accord avec moi
c'est juste le fait de ne pas pouvoir
accueillir le public
joli la raison de tuer a raison de
rappeler que c'est un des sports qui
finalement aurait pu on aurait pu même
être pratiqué pendant l'office
confinement d'ailleurs il
on a eu on a eu avec la fédération
française de golf de deux très
intéressante et très longues
négociations avec le ministère des
sports au ministère de la santé pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les golfs
réouvre le 11 mai dernier mais il a
fallu montrer patte blanche
et effectivement rappelé que quasiment
paraissait bon saut par définition le
golf le golf est un sport de distance
sociale puisque on a un partenaire qui
peut mettre sa maladroite un partenaire
sam à la gauche l'autre droit devant
mais jamais on s'enfuira porte pour les
de mal donc sauf au départ vos débats et
encore au départ tu es de toute façon tu
es à la distance d'un club c'est un
autre événement qui a été annulé la
course à pied paris versailles le rendez
vous attire chaque année près de 25
mille coureurs entre la tour eiffel et
le château de versailles même question
est-ce qu'il fallait l'annuler
oui oui oui oui pour ian wilson
pierre-louis pour stéphane et oui pour
hélène hélène pourquoi de toute façon
par définition la course on peut pas
faire des départs en différé avec
licence au départ les beaucoup trop
ondes
si non c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout envisageable de garder bien garder
bonne chose pour vous oui c'est pas
possible de respecter la distanciation
même en faisant des départs différés on
se rattrape tôt ou tard on est collé les
autres c'est impossible et il fallait la
nuée solution alors d'autres événements
font quant à eux se tenir cette année le
tour de france 2020 été dépassé à la fin
de l'été la grande boucle sera
programmée du 29 août au 20 septembre
la dernière étape passera par les
yvelines pour la deuxième année
consécutive le peloton s'élancera de
manta jeu en direction des champs
elysées pour 122 kilomètres de son côté
le tournoi de tennis de roland garros
soit pour hamé du 20 septembre au 4
octobre porte d'auteuil de nombreux
jeunes ramasseurs de balles yves
moisseron sur l'événement et des
tennismans du département pourrait
également être présent comme arthur
reeves darkness pareil ces événements
est ce qu'il fallait les maintenir ou
pas à tour de france roland garros oui
vous êtes si mauvais stéphane il fallait
maintenir tout cela dépend du ça dépend
de l'évolution ou pas du coronavirus
c'est si l'on trouvait des des
médicaments des vaccins tout ça on sait
pas pour l'instant on est en blanc dans
l'inconnu cet homme c'est encore loin
donc on prépare mon emploi au niveau de
l'épidémie à ce niveau là vient de
germer dans les faits c'est sûr que
c'est obligatoire entre ses hobbies
c'est obligatoire mais s'est battu un
tour de france s'est plaint de monuments
qui ont qui ont besoin d'avoir leur
compétition conserver conserver cette
année je suis désolé mais on doit
terminer aussi le tournoi des six
nations et toi il va se finir sais pas
c'est pas possible
et ça va être très compliqué je ne sais
pas quels sont les instants sur laquelle
question de décision là dessus mais
voilà on peut pas on doit en finir
malheureusement sans grand chelem mais
voilà pour moi bien sûr qu'un tour de
france doit avoir lieu bien sûr qu'à
roland garros doit avoir lieu mais la
même chose pour wimbledon
voilà il fallait réagir et hors mode et
les robes modéliser les calendriers il
faut savoir une chose c'est que ce virus
il va disparaître dans les semaines à
venir de sa de sa de sa belle mort et
puis réapparaîtra mais comme la grippe
tu sais que tu peux dire ce que tu veux
mais comme la grippe comme la bible
disparaît tous les tous les atouts les
achats nous n'avons pas entendu il ya
déjà riez pas longtemps nous n'avons pas
encore d'éléments là dessus dans l'est
il ya un an
il ya un moment il ya un moment c'est un
kobe des les comités dans l'est c'est
pareil on ne siffle pas la piste alors
que les gens qui sont spécialistes des
ducs au vide nous disent nos disques à
partir du moment où le virus est en
contact avec l'eau qui perd 50% de sa de
sa contamination
il ya un moment faux faux faux être faut
être réaliste on est surprotégé
aujourd'hui donc et on est en plus on
est surprotégé pour une très faible
partie de la population n'utilise
c'était je pense qu'il a dit il a dit
beaucoup de conneries tu mets a marre
des sports oms par les sports en
transport la part export et par le sport
mais justement je trouve que le sport
est très très impacté et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va avoir va subir les
conséquences pendant de longues années
derrière suite à ce suite à ce qu vide
en tout cas on va partir sur un
rendez-vous qui il bonne note et on va
dire un rendez vous qui va se tenir à
priori le départ du vendée globe 2020
est programmé le 8 novembre donc de
l'ucl un docu les sables d'olonne en
vendée sur ce tour du monde en solitaire
on devrait retrouver louis burton le
skipper originaire de rambouillet le
sportif de 34 ans participera à son
troisième vendée globe il avait terminé
7e de la dernière édition louis burton
nous a justement voyez une réaction on
est en train de finaliser la préparation
de bureau vallée la mise à l'eau on va
attaquer normalement la qualification de
2000 milles
au mois de juin afin d'être prêt pour
s'entraîner sur la performance au mois
de juillet au mois d'août et au mois de
septembre
l'idée étant d'arriver sur ce vendée
globe
donc avec un très bon bateau préparé par
une équipe performante et avec un
objectif de faire mieux que la dernière
fois en 2016-2017 où j'avais pu terminer
7e de la course sur le précédent bureau
vallée donc ben un top 7
et idéalement un top 5 et voilà et merci
pour votre soutien
c'est important votre avis sur les
tenues du vendée globe le genre
justement avec l'essence et par foyer
par contre doit là au moins au moins
voilà une discipline qui honore le
corridor juste revenir très rapidement
sur les événements que le tour de france
et roland garros qui pour moi outre le
l'aspect sportif à chaud un aspect
financier pour le maintien de ces
compétitions et tout ce qui va autour
les partenaires le partenariat et
tourner un petit peu autour de l'aspect
financier
et c'est pour ça qu'on on insiste pour
les faire pour pocket des lieux quoi
elle s'est pas spécialement sportif quoi
mais chez d'accord avec jean on joue pas
dans la même cour et c'est une question
d'enjeu d'enjeux majeurs
quand on parle de roland garros du tour
de france du vendée globe c'est qu'une
exposition nationale internationale
mondiale et évidemment on parle ne
serait-ce que von opel de france l'open
de france de golf qui est un qui est un
des plus qu est le plus vieil open
continentale hors îles britanniques où
je vous parle je vous parle la même cour
il n'a pas les mêmes impacts n'a pas le
même poids quand il s'agit de se dire
qu'il faut maintenir ou pas maintenir
il ya une priorité de date pour ces
grands événements qui sont des sondés
faire valoir pour la france notamment et
pour le tour de france et roland garros
et qui sont impératif de tenir si on
peut le faire évidemment dans des
conditions sanitaires les plus
sécuritaire possible
c'est très très rapidement à la dernière
thématique c'est sur les sports qui vont
être pratiqués la france manque de sens
pratique en ce moment et sport qui ne
qui ne le sont pas
il y a des sports notamment le golf qui
est pratiquée en ce moment c'est
vraiment le sport à pratiquer en ce
moment malgré tout ça a été une grosse
bataille pour pour le auprès du
ministère des sports et de la santé
comme je disais tout à l'heure mais
effectivement une activité vers permet
d'avoir respecté la discrétion
dispensation sociale l'a récemment
depuis hier les terrasses des
restaurants bars et restaurants du golfe
parisien et partout ailleurs dans la
zone verte sont réouverts donc il ya de
ces de convier les racines ne sont pas
un sport qui acheva liés bon après ça
fait partie des valeurs des valeurs de
ce beau sport à pratiquer oui donc
maintenant n'hésitez pas venez venez
essayer le golf c'est c'est le moment le
tennis également possible à pratiquer
est ce que vous en pensez il ya de
jarrier bien sûr ça fait partie des 10
sport qui sont logiques de pouvoir
pratiquer le tennis de table
aussi je suis désolé après le squash et
bien sûr que c'est pas c'est pas la même
chose pour rester dans les sports de
raquette mais bien sûr qu'il y a
énormément de sport qui peuvent être
pratiqué le cyclisme aujourd'hui on
emballe chevreuse basse et c'est c'est
aussi possible même moment même en petit
groupe
les sports individuels absolument
transport individuel ou même s'il n'a
pas de contact avec ton adversaire avoir
d'interdiction et les retours puisque la
pole dance est justement pour vous il ya
encore une interdiction c'est ouais mais
ce mois ces sujets qui fâchent léger non
un support chacun aucun échange physique
alors une distanciation physique
nécessaire on peut tout faire en fait
c'est vraiment sauf que voilà nom et
d'espoirs qui sont pour l'instant
interdit entre ica et qui pourrait
l'être pendant de nombreuses semaines
c'est la boxe et le rugby par exemple
est-ce que vous me comprenez jean pax
donc je disais oui je reprenais
qu'hélène les 10 pour la pole dance
c'était ccfc pas évident parce que je
suppose que ces périodes là il faut
c'est tellement un jeu régulièrement
depuis hier de plusieurs compétiteurs
c'est le rugby c'est problématique parce
que c'est vraiment un sport de contact
ce combat commun contre ledit de combat
et d'évitement et que pour l'instant
mais la distinction sociale elle est
loin d'y être
on a la possibilité de reprendre mais
avec un ballon désinfecter tous les
quarts d'heure avec les joueurs à 10
mètres les uns des autres
maximum dix joueurs fait bon donc
policiers vous pourriez du couple et le
placage c'est quand on tient les impôts
c'est très bien et les nouvelles sont
vraiment pas pour stephen et stéphane on
parlait tout à l'heure sur la partie
vaccins et autres quand même la machine
look qui est dit que le rugby nous
pourrait reprendre que quand on aurait
trouvé un vaccin a forcément gagné sur
cette note un peu pessimiste un pierre
chevallier mais bon on espère en tout
cas le sport local rencontre à dix très
rapidement c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation j'ai posé une citation
c'est comme ça c'est le timing de
l'émission alors on va terminer par une
citation de l'ancien basketteur michael
jordan il fait beaucoup parler de lui en
ce moment avec le documentaire the last
dance
je peux accepter un échec tout le monde
peut échouer mais je ne peux pas
accepter de ne pas essayer je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78 habitants
[Musique]
non